the back story behind cookies because
cookies has become
i mean
weed aside
i feel like it's the best seller at
zoomies it's gotta be i mean every time
i go to zoomies this i mean
front of the window all over the country
the clothing line itself has just became
its own monster man like
it's it's dope as [ __ ] because i never
thought it would last this long you see
clothing lines kind of like rise and dip
yeah always we ain't dip bro we're still
going i think there's so much more
growth and i think the reason why it's
popping is because clothes are dope the
accessories are dope it's innovative
it's it's fly it looks clean it's not
too much like
and like i did it the right way like i
never like i watched clothing companies
back in the days to send huge boxes to
people and i never did that bro i never
i had too much pride as an artist as
well to beg other artists to promote my
[ __ ] i just let that [ __ ] right off my
fan base and my fan base and my
supporters started blowing that [ __ ] up
and i still don't know how that [ __ ] is
yeah it used to be like i'd go to the
airport and if i saw someone with some
cookie [ __ ] on i'd be like oh do you
know like do you know burn or like you
know like
because it was a very small like niche
type of community but now everyone has
cookies you know what side to me cookies
out groomy people know who cookie what
cookies is and don't know me and that's
amazing because before it was the other
way around yeah yeah before they'd be
like oh yeah bernie but
people see people with cookies on like
you know burn like who
this is amazing it worked what is like
like
give people like an idea of i've heard i
mean i heard some numbers a couple of
years ago like about how how good y'all
were doing on the clothing side
but like give me an idea on how good
this thing is is doing right now only
because i love you i always if you look
at any interview i always say i'm not
talking numbers but you know at some
point in time like you know i see all
the rappers online flexing with their
you know their cast by their ear and
[ __ ] i don't do that [ __ ] but
i mean i guess i'll flex today i mean
cookies on pat like probably like um
i think 50 55 million this year clothing
just clothing just clothing yeah last
year we did 32 million clothing
it feels great
congrats man and and the tight thing is
it's like we just got started bro like
we haven't even opened up flagship
stores everywhere we haven't really went
to other countries yet like we haven't
really done what we're about to do you
know there's the future forecast of
cookies clothing just the clothing not
the weed just the clothing is pretty
dope yeah and i think too like just some
of the like
collabs and like the licensing like when
you guys do like the scarface line or
the the goodfellas line that just came
out sick like it's always on point and
some of the next ones we have coming are
gonna shock the [ __ ] out of people like
some of the ones that we've locked down
is incredible like i can't even believe
we got it